Sáng ngày mời sảo tháng tám tại hồ hoàn kếm hàn nổi, bảo nhân dân phối hợp phí bộ công an, tổ chức lẽ phát động hạt lợp đi bộ vàng quốc, cùng Việt Nam tiến nước.
Tới sự có đồng chỉ lẽ quốc mình, huy vien Trung uân đàng, tổn viên tập bảo nhân dân, phó trưởng ban tiến sáo và dân bản Trung uân, chủ tịch hội nhà báo Việt Nam.
Lồng chỉ thưởng tướng tranh quốc tò, huy vien Trung uân đàng, thứ trưởng bộ công an, cùng đại diện các ban bộ, gành, loàn thể Trung uân và hàn nổi.
Sự kiện diễn sả đồng thời tại bá mấy tư tình thành phố, bá nhìn 8,5 mút sả, phường, đặc khu hành chính, với hàng trong nghiên người dân và lực lượng vũ trang tham sả, hướng ở mục tiêu một tì bức tranh tiến vào kiện vinh mối.
Chương trình được tổ chức nhân kiện nghiệp tám mấy năm cách mặng tháng tám, quốc hánh mồng hải tháng chính và ngày trên thống công an nhân dân.
Măng ý nghĩa chính chỉ sả hội sâu sắc, thể hiện tinh thành bản kết, yêu nước và khát vọng xây dựng lất nước hùng cường bệnh vướng.
Đừng ngày 25 tháng bệnh đến mấy sò tháng tám, người dân cả nước đã tích cực đang kỹ trực tuyến, mỗi bức tranh được khi nhận là một bức xanh gó phần bảo vệ môi trường, hướng tới mục tiêu net se row.
Tại điểm câu trung tâm, các đại biểu và quân trung nhân dân đã hoặc áo đỏ sau vang cùng theo dõi lệ thượng cơ tổ quốc, hát góca và bức vào hành chính đi bộ.
Lực lượng công an nhân dân, đống phải tròn nòng cốt trong tổ chức, và đặc kết hợp tiến chuyển pháp luật, phòng trống tội phạm và bảo đam an ninh chặt tư.
Sư kẻ nhận được sự đồng hành của nhiều sách nghiệp lớn như Việt cóm bành Pecholi MICE Gờ Lêス Group, T-HAT Group Việt Nam Elice và Sabeco.
Gó phần lan phạm thông biệm một Việt Nam khoải máy loàn kết, chắc nhận và giấu khách phòng vừa lên.
Với tinh thần, châu trải tiêm, một lức trân, trung khách phòng, cùng Việt Nam tiến bước không chỉ là ngày hội thể thao, mà còn là hành trình gắn kết cộng đồng, thấp lên nghiệm từ hào sân tạo và khẳng định quyết tâm của bàn sân.
Tòan quân, trong xây dựng một kết Nam hùng cường bứng bước bảo dân Lê.